all right John and Jill are with us in
Philadelphia hey guys how are you good
Dave hi Dave aqua do you two welcome to
a millionaire theme hour what's your net
worth
we have about 2.2 million awesome and
it's invested in what we have our house
which is about 400 to 450 commercial
real estate which is about 650
retirements about 800 and the rest in
cash okay cool
all right how much of this did you
inherit how old are you guys
well I am 44 and I'm 52 okay and what's
your average income over your working
lifetime household income well we have a
we range from a hundred thousand to two
hundred fifty thousand we are both small
business owners so it varies from year
to year gotcha okay and what are your
degrees in well I have a my undergrad
degree is actually I'm supposed to be a
high school English teacher but I also
have my master's in business okay and
I'm an electrical engineer and also
business degree okay
so business degrees all right and GPAs
oh I think mine's about a 3.43 three
here okay cool
all right so at 44 and 52 years old you
have 2.2 million dollars you live in
Philadelphia a third of it approximately
approaching half of it is in real estate
the rest is in cash in and investments
how did you do this what caused it hmm
well I think we both have the same
mindset to live below our means that's
the common theme today but the other
thing that I think causes a lot of hard
work in general never working less than
40 hours a week generally probably
around 50 to 60 hours a week or early on
and and then now we're able to actually
work a little bit less but in the
beginning working very hard and then
debt keeping our debt low
we actually waited to buy a house until
we saved up enough to buy the house in
cash and and then we also put our kids
through college and we didn't take any
loans for them and we didn't let them
take any loans what kind of business do
you have well I own a business that does
training so we create online training
and John on the different business I do
engineering support for manufacturing ok
and are the incomes about half and half
between the two are one of them more
than the other one about about equal
they vary though year to year so know
yours Jill does better than I do and
vice versa gotcha
ok cool how many new cars have you
bought well in the last 15 years I think
between the two of us - how long have
you been married 15 years yeah okay so
you got married at 30 or 29 did I do
that right Jill and I and I was
remarried okay all right cool very cool
so what's the most expensive jeans
you've bought well we've been arguing
this but I think we're another one of
these Costco shoppers so and I say the
same thing under 30 bucks okay all right
yeah and what part does giving play in
your financial equation we we always
give money to local charities and
especially when there are things like
tsunamis and hurricanes and there's like
a lot of you know a lot of desperation
and grief out there we try to kick in
big time for those events but generally
locally we devote our time some money to
all the local charities and we're always
doing something gotcha yeah I think I
think that's a big part of when you get
to this stage it's just amazing each
month to sit there and go well you know
which organization will we like to give
to this month and we try and carve out a
certain set amount each month that we
can do that so a lot of intentional
giving them absolutely yeah we you know
David it's funny because I actually just
are
listening to your radio show about two
three months ago and so we've walked
this path but we really didn't know
about you before that and I wish we did
because then I think we wouldn't feel so
weird you are weird but it's a good way
and you know I think now that there's
that you have given a voice to how to do
this yeah which is phenomenal because
it's what we did and and so now I feel
like we're able to be in that spot where
we can we can give like no one else can
give and moving forward we're just
looking forward to that
very cool well thank you Joe and John
from Philadelphia you are rock stars
you're great American heroes making a
small business at a 2.2 million dollars
in net worth at 54 52 and 44 years old